كنت متعبًا جدًا لدرجة أنني كنت أنام
طوال اليوم وكانت معدتي تؤلمني بشدة لدرجة
أنني لم أشعر بهذا القدر من
الألم الشديد من قبل
كان هذا هو الشيء الأكثر رعبًا الذي رأيته على الإطلاق
لأنه كان مجرد الحياة التي
تركتها للتو  وأنا فقط اعتقدت أن هذا
هو الخطأ لماذا بشرتك
خضراء جدًا ولماذا تتجمد يديها وقدميها
، أعني أنك كنت تعتقد حقًا أن
أليس قد تموت ،
لا أحب مطلقًا أن أعتقد أنها قد
ماتت إلا مائة  في المائة كنت قد
بدأت في التفكير في
جينيفر وزميلي جيك
تابر والدا أليس البالغان من العمر 15 عامًا ، حيث
أرادوا جميعًا مشاركة قصتهم كقصة
تحذيرية وإلقاء الضوء على كيف أن
شيئًا شائعًا جدًا يمكن علاجه يمكن
أن يحدث بشكل خاطئ للغاية
وبدأت في التقيؤ  في صباح يوم السبت
ومرضت حقًا ، لم أكن أتحسن تمامًا ،
لذلك أخذني والداي
للذهاب إلى المستشفى على الأرجح
التشخيص في الوقت الذي
يُحتمل أن تكون آلام المعدة فيه دليلًا على بيانات التهاب المعدة والأمعاء للتسمم
الغذائي وأحد الحالات الحرجة الأخرى
الحكم على المكونات هو ما
يستخدمه الأطباء لمحاولة اتخاذ القرارات ، على
سبيل المثال ، يعتبر الألم في أسفل البطن الأيمن
أحد أكثر
أعراض التهاب الزائدة الدودية شيوعًا ، ومع ذلك فإن أقل
من نصف المصابين
بالتهاب الزائدة الدودية لديهم النمط الكلاسيكي
حيث كنت تعاني من الألم  لقد
شعرت بألم في جميع أنحاء بطني بدلاً من
رباعي الأيمن فقط بالطريقة التي
استبعدوا بها التهاب الزائدة الدودية ، حيث تم اختبار القفز ،
وقد طُلب مني القفز وقد تمكنت من
الحصول على بوصة واحدة من الأرض
واستبعد ذلك فقط التهاب الزائدة الدودية
لجميع  الأطباء وذلك عندما أعلنوا للتو
أنها عدوى فيروسية
ولكن إدراك التحيزات أمر مهم للغاية
يرأس الدكتور براشانت ماهاجان
قسم طب الطوارئ للأطفال في
جامعة
ميشيغان ويقول إن التشخيص الخاطئ يمكن أن يحدث جزئيًا
بسبب الزخم التشخيصي كل
عام تقريبًا 25000  يصاب الأطفال
بالتهاب الزائدة الدودية ووفقًا لهذه الدراسة التي
نشرها الدكتور ماهاجان في عام 2020 ، فإن ما يقرب من
خمسة بالمائة من الوقت يعد
ألف مرة في السنة تعكس
القصة قصة ما حدث لأليس
تابر بعد ذلك
في الواقع مرت أكثر من ثلاثة
أيام مؤلمة في المستشفى دون
أكثر من مسكنات الألم قبل أن
تتمكن عائلة تابر أخيرًا من الحصول على
بعض الإجابات
ولكن بحلول ذلك الوقت كانت أليس قد ساءت.
كان السبب في معاناتها من
هذا الألم واسع النطاق هو أن
الزائدة الدودية قد تمزق بالفعل مما أدى إلى
إصابة شديدة وتعفن الدم. يعتبر
استئصال الزائدة الدودية أحد أكثر
عمليات الأطفال شيوعًا التي يتم إجراؤها
عادةً وتستغرق حوالي ساعة ويستغرق التعافي
بضعة أسابيع في حالة أليس.
لم يكن بالإمكان
إجراء العملية لأن تجويف بطنها أصبح
الآن مليئًا بالسوائل الملوثة
، كان عليّ الحصول على مصرفين لتنظير الدهون في
البداية ، ثم بعد أن
أخرجوني وأرسلوني إلى المنزل ، عدت إلى
المستشفى لأنني ما زلت لا أشعر
أفضل وكان عليهم وضع
تصريف شحمي آخر لي ، انتهى
بي الأمر بإخراج الزائدة الدودية بعد 12 أسبوعًا
في مارس.  كانت حياتك كما كانت خلال
تلك الأسابيع الاثني عشر ، فقد فقدت الكثير
من الوزن من دخول المستشفى لدرجة أنني كنت أعاني من
أجل تناول الطعام وقادر على العمل ، كان من
الممكن أن يحدث هذا لأي طفل
في أي مستشفى
في الولايات المتحدة لأن الأطباء ليسوا على
دراية كافية
بكيفية  غالبًا ما يكون التهاب الزائدة الدودية
غير موجود بطريقة قياسية ، فقد
مرت تسعة أشهر منذ أن خضعت أليس تابر
أخيرًا لعملية استئصال الزائدة الدودية ، وبعد
وقت مظلم بشكل خاص ،
سمحت لنفسها مرة أخرى بالبدء في
الحلم بالمستقبل ولكن لديها الآن مهمة جديدة
أيضًا  أريد أن ألتحق بكلية روان
وربما أدرس علم الحيوان ،
أنا فقط أحب كيف تسير حياتي
وأعتقد أنها كانت حقًا أتمنى
ألا يحدث لي أبدًا ولكني
أعتقد أنها كانت تجربة تعليمية مهمة حقًا
بالنسبة لي.
يعرفون أنهم بحاجة إلى الدفاع عن
أنفسهم